donc c'est chez vous ici un depuis de
nombreuses années quelle année là depuis
presque quinze ans mais j'ai passé toute
mon enfance sur ce jeu là c'est vrai et
là comment vous allez quatre mois après
cette démission fracassante à petit
personnel privée familiale
tout va bien j'ai retrouvé un rythme de
vie ma famille après dès que votre
esprit et votre conscience se réveille
vous regardez l'état du monde ce qui se
passe en france
le dernier rapport du giec puisque votre
constat quand même sur l'état de la
planète il est assez honnêtement je suis
assez inquiet je suis inquiet parce que
je suis inquiet en même temps je garde
l'espoir garde espoir parce que si
l'intelligence de l'homme voulait bien
se coordonner je pense qu'on peut
résoudre toutes les équations encore
maintenant on a très peu de temps la vie
sur terre tient du miracle
on a envoyé des sondes partout
d'ailleurs dernièrement il y en a une
qualité je crois dans le point le plus
éloigné on n'avait jamais été il n'y a
pas l'ombre des dribbles commencement de
preuve de vie est le seul petit endroit
dans l'univers infini où la vie est plus
essais mais c'est sur terre donc on
bénéficie ce miracle mais il tient à
très peu de choses
il tient à une petite pellicule au
dessus de la tête qu'on a pas de
l'atmosphère
si on en change la composition contraint
de le faire pas sûr que la vie puisse
continuer à s'épanouir
il ya une petite couche qu'on a sous les
pieds pas ici mais là ça peut l humus et
sans laquelle on peut pas se nourrir
et si chacun avait conscience de ça je
pense qu on se prosterne ray tous les
jours devant revenir un peu de la vie
[Musique]
vous êtes l'homme politique préféré des
français vous n'avez pas réussi à
convaincre le gouvernement de bouger
comment on va faire pour convaincre les
gouvernements qu'il faut affronter
sérieusement les diseurs de la planète
nous n'avions pas la même conscience de
l'importance des changements qu'il
fallait opérer c'est pas le même
diagnostic ne pas le même diagnostic je
lui dis dans une formule que peut-être
pas très heureuse mais enfin vous vous
mettez pas dans la même situation
si vous pensez vous avez une branche it
ou si vous avez un cancer mais en face
de métastases et la planète est dans une
situation de cancer très avancé un plan
marshall qu'il faut non là n'est pas là
parce que l'apathie elle est partout
ouvertement je veux pas faire croire
qu'avec eux des moyens limités
on va résoudre des équations aussi
complexe et moi quand je réclame que par
exemple les banques centrales comme
elles l'ont fait en 2008 pour sauver le
système bancaire puisse émettre des
milliers de milliards de dollars ou
d'euros pour investir dans la transition
énergétique parce que ça va nous
épargner les dépenses considérables et
que quand on investit pour la sobriété
énergétique quand on investit pour
produire de l'énergie à partir d'énergie
qui sont gratuites à terme c'est pas des
dépenses inutiles
si on sort pas des sentiers battus alors
qu'on est dans une situation inédite
l'humanité ne s'est jamais trouvé dans
une situation aussi délicate avec des
menaces d'une telle amplitude
si on reste dans les chemins
traditionnels on trompe son monde et moi
je ne voulais pas trompé son monde
n'avait mis en cause les groupes
d'intérêt par exemple vous êtes en
permanence confrontés à des intérêts
particuliers qui additionné ne font ne
font pas évidemment l'intérêt général
donc on parle des pétrolières de
l'industrie agricole
j'avais quand vous êtes ministre de la
transition écologique et solidaire comme
je l'étais vous êtes à la croisée de
tous les groupes de pression automobile
pétroliers chimiques agricoles que
sais-je encore on entretient une forme
de comment dire de mystification on
pense que l'écologie c'est juste une
changement de cap c'est vraiment un
changement logiciel c'est un changement
de paradigme
si nous avions 40 ans pour résoudre ce
sujet là je pense qu'on a été très loin
dans l'excès que l'humanité va revenir
une forme de sagesse de sobriété externe
on n'a plus le temps vous dit si tu sais
on n'a plus le temps on n'a plus le
temps il temps pour beaucoup de tout ça
ça reste lointain quoique dans nos
propres pays et y compris chez un de vos
voisins aux états unis en californie et
les conséquences des changements
climatiques c'est plus une vue de
l'esprit
moi quand j'étais ministre je devais
régler des problèmes d'érosion trait de
côte qui était impensable avant c'était
hier maintenant avec des gens qui sont
dans les habitations sont menacées par
le recul du trait de côte
nous nous avions des inondations à
répétition ce que nous n'avions pas des
extrêmes climatiques voilà il commence à
avoir des problèmes maintenant pour
adapter d'agriculture à des changements
de température donc les phénomènes sont
même visible à l'oeil nu
y compris chez nous avant évidemment il
fallait aux philippines au sahel pour se
rendre compte ou dans les îles
océaniennes des conséquences du
changement climatique mais les phénomène
s'accélère et médisants à partir de
maintenant la solution elle passe par où
selon vous il faut que le citoyen donne
un message implicite clair une sorte d'
injonction politique en disant on nous
sommes prêts voyez en france il ya eu
des jours ci une initiative s'appelle la
sphère du siècle où en l'espace de
quelques jours plus d'un million 8 de
citoyens ont demandé à l'état dans une
action juridique d'agir conformément aux
objectifs notamment que la france a pris
à la coop 21 au québec on a un pacte de
transition aussi bon mais il faut que ça
me plaît mais il faut aussi que les gens
on descend dans la rue pour son pouvoir
d'achat et je le comprends mais enfin on
descend très faiblement dans la rue pour
l'avenir de ses enfants est-ce qu'on
descend dans la rue pour sachant que la
tel qu'on est parti en cours de siècles
nos enfants ne pourront plus voir
d'éléphants de lyon à l'état sauvage
probablement dans le monde que la
biodiversité est en train de disparaître
comme le sable dans la main donc faut
aussi que le citoyen un moment ou un
autre
au-delà de ces difficultés immédiates il
s'exprime là il ya eu par exemple hier
en france une pétition les gens
demandent une journée par semaine où on
ne mange pas de viande n'est pas de
poisson il faut que ce type d'initiative
se multiplient mais alors que du coup de
l'autre côté les politiques se
saisissent de ça et pour vous
personnellement donc l'action maintenant
elle est en dehors des gouvernements je
pense que je dois être résolument du
côté des porteurs de solutions parce que
les solutions existent mais elles
restent l'exception alors qu'elles
doivent devenir la norme comment faire
en sorte de créer une espèce de lobby
des consciences de faire émerger un
lobby des consciences qui exprime ce à
quoi elles sont prêts et qui impose au
gouvernement d'une manière très
pacifique
les 10-15 mesure qui permet
véritablement de rentrer dans une
mutation irréversible et qui soit à la
hauteur des enjeux
il ya probablement un peu d'utopie dans
ce que je suis en train de vous dire je
pense que la seule utopie aujourd'hui
c'est de penser qu'on peut continuer le
modèle existence et que ça va bien se
terminer
ça c'est l'utopie coloniaux merci
beaucoup merci à vous bon retour au
québec merci
[Musique]